if you don't follow Steve Byrne at Steve
Byrne follow him and all that jeepers in
live whatever he burned alive check it
out okay
yeah and you know what and I can also
tell Steve yeah I can tell that that you
will be on this podcast soon sooner than
you think
I can I can tell that there's a little
bit of a spark here and I'm not saying
that we're like there's anything sexual
going on yeah and here's another thing
that you get you get really homophobic
with me no Bobby you that's another
thing that I wanted to mention that's
right
alright when I go to the comedy store
right and I wanna ugh I've never given
me reason to weird around you no other
way no no I want one what you did the
punchline oh sure I tell you what I'll
defend myself go ahead you wonder what
yeah go ahead
so I finished my set I what I don't know
if you the punchline greenroom is very
tiny it's tight okay yeah cover your
eyes cuz you know what you did he just
realize hey why I didn't really like him
tonight open the door
right I open the door and I walk in and
nobody's in and then all of a sudden I
hear the door shut he was hiding behind
the door I just heard shut I turn around
I'm scared and you're standing there
naked you're standing there butt naked
you go crud Korean hello you go hug
Korean hello yes I go give it a long way
for me hug walk away from me hug and you
keep coming towards me and I was kicking
you I remember that now yeah right yeah
now let me say something okay I want you
hug me you push in to push in you do you
remember that the pelvis push yeah I
apologize you know what I apologize you
know what those kind of behaviors really
are you being real yeah okay sit sit
right with me and we I was gonna make
some sort of funny comeback yeah or just
who I am this and that you know when I
hear just now yeah you know I'm sorry
Bobby
I was laughing at the time and I do
think it there we go there
right Shrek reverse we do a [ __ ]